in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Andy is
with us hi Andy how are you I'm great
glad to meet you good to meet you sir
welcome to Nashville where do you live
in wood West Virginia which is in there
Martinsburg oh very nice cool fun and so
you're here to do your debt-free screen
that's right I love it how much have you
paid off sir two hundred and six
thousand Wow how long did that take you
44 months love it and making what kind
of money during that time initially 145
K uh-huh about a year ago I cut back to
half time at home so I don't have to go
down so put my half time and okay
all right fine now is that your home and
everything you paid off yeah so you're
completely debt-free house and
everything everything congratulations
I live in the trailer you know wat in a
punk in a park uh-huh and pay 350 years
of renting little electric bill that's
about it oh that's good keep up my 15
year old car so what was the what was
the two hundred six thousand dollars in
debt I had 133 K in the house 20 on
credit cards and eight on a car loan and
then the house was underwater about
forty thousand I paid forty five
thousand during 2013 on that okay so you
sold the home
I sold the home but it took nine months
to get rid of it okay all right and so
what did the house sell for i sold for a
hundred and twenty which realized me
about a $1,500 area but so of the two
hundred and six thousand and debt 120
was the sale of house
well actually 92 is what he paid off the
house the rest of it i cash flowed okay
I see Wow
pretty incredible congratulations was
the hard year that it was I bet it was
so what happened forty four months ago
that made you go on this journey tell me
your story I'm sorry and I were getting
kind of old you know ain't no spring
chicken anymore
but we've seen we weren't in the best
shape and things weren't gonna go good
until we started looking for a way to do
things and about a year before I got
doing this we went through crown
financial oh very good got a lot of
awareness and motivation but no plan
it needed a user manual so then in
August in between I figured out how by
paying some more extra on everything it
would eventually go away but boy it
didn't go away fast enough so when we
came in and in August of 11 and sherry
was on disability so we went and got the
home study kit and we went through that
whole thing in about three days and
really got excited about the gazelles
good and so so the crown financial in
combination with FPU causes you to be
able to do this all right excellent very
cool so then for about eight months then
we were working together hard on it at
home and then she went uh went to the
doctor one day for a routine colonoscopy
uh-huh they found a little critter in
there so she went into some surgery they
took out some of the intestine over the
next ten months they operated three
times there wasn't anything left so
January of thirteen she said just take
me home yeah because I can't eat
anything I can't do anything and so on
we did we spent five days at hospice at
home all of her four boys were there
with me though 405 days I don't know
anyway after that I had to revive a
little guy on myself so I said well I'm
gonna cut everything down I cut the
house in half no closed everything off
got rid of the cable or the TV on the
cable I still got the Internet I work on
that and oh my god so you finished up
the project that you all had started
together right immediately she had the
security glance said keep a little extra
in the emergency fund
well I took what was left in there above
the 1000 and paid off the remainder of
what was due on that so we were finished
step to that month okay and then I had
to rebuild an emergency fund and pay off
the house of course it had a big shovel
then yeah and so I was able to do all
that of course I was living on the
Social Security which you know cost me
about eighteen hundred a month to live
on and they got into the guy's dead to
save up for the trailer after the end of
13 and so I and by July of 14 that was
ready to move into the trailer and put
the house on the market then it was wait
nine months and in March of this year
finally sold for just enough to get out
from under it
very cool it's a long story and we had a
long journey you've been on so how old
was Cherie when she passed she was
almost 66 she was how long what y'all
been married 16 years
okay yeah we both met after some
unfortunate experiences in life and we
had both sworn off when or could ever
get married with anybody we're sitting
talked for about a year and all of a
sudden one day I just turned around
turned I said let's get married yeah
damn the Sevierville I want to see Jimmy
temple in the feed store there you go
got married down there then we drove
back up again well why not like it
that's fun well congratulations Andy
it's a big milestone for you you've been
through a lot and how does it feel now
to be standing here completely debt-free
well you know I can't tell you that I
feel any different because 72 years old
I only have 140 kid in exam accounts so
my Social Security I'm living on all the
money and make up my 20 to 25 hour a
week goes into there I'm hoping that by
the end of 16 I'll have
two-fifty in there I think you will and
then that'll be just 74 and sit back and
relax what do you do for a living I did
some computer work for a company
contractor down in the DC area okay but
it's all home from boom yeah sure
absolutely
well congratulations sir I'm proud of
you
thank you I'm sure sherry smiling at you
right now I think yeah I do I love it
alright Andy and sherry from Winchester
West Virginia two hundred and six
thousand dollars paid off in 44 months
making one hundred and forty-five now at
halftime and now finishing up his
retirement count it down let's hear a
debt free scream Andy sherry this one's
for you
we're dad free I love it congratulations
sir well done